une construction neuve
de Saint-Michel qu'ils ont fait
construire il y a 6 ans elle savait que
la valeur de sa maison à la grimper mais
pas
d'autantveloppe en fait on a vu qu'on
avait un ours de 105 %. qu'est-ce que tu
t'es dit à ce moment-là
conséquence son compte de taxes
municipal a aussi fait un bon
vertigineux il était de 6000 dollars
l'an dernier il a passé à 7600 dollars
cette année et ce n'est pas terminé dans
trois ans tu seras pas loin de 10000
dollars de taxes à payer elle s'est
rapidement demandé pourquoi son
évaluation foncière est passée de 760
000 à plus de 1 million 500000 dollars
mon premier réflexe ça a été d'aller
voir les comparables les évaluations on
a des maisons comparables dans mon
quartier et je me suis rendu compte que
la moyenne de la hausse de ces maisons
dans mon quartier était d'à peu près 50%
alors que nous c'est 105% . donc je me
suis dit c'est pas normal elle a donc
communiqué avec l'évaluateur de la Ville
de Montréal attitré à son dossier et la
réponse elle a évaluateur à ça quand je
mets en effet pas c'est de dire vous
pouvez pas vous comparer parce que
l'erreur est peut-être chez propriété là
il m'a dit madame vous êtes seulement
malchanceux
pour rétablir la valeur des propriétés
la Ville de Montréal examine des
milliers de transactions immobilières
chaque année les prix de vente de ces
immeubles servant ensuite à déterminer
la valeur de tous les autres c'est ce
qu'on appelle l'évaluation de masse mais
certaines maisons font l'objet d'une
évaluation particulière c'est ce qui est
arrivé agence 3 c'est assez opaque aussi
comme
méthode c'est très arbitraire la ville
explique que c'est le résultat de
l'évaluation particulière qui prime si
jamais il y a une écart significative
entre les deux approches c'est sûr que
je vais contester mon évaluation
et c'est aussi ce que songe à faire de
nombreux autres citoyens ceux qui ont vu
la valeur de leurs propriétés augmenter
au-delà de la moyenne de 35% dans le
rôle foncier 2023 2025 verront leur
compte de taxes grimpées je trouve que
c'est un petit peu trop exagéré
qu'on nous si on veut récem à Montréal
il faut avoir des taxes qui sont
raisonnables sinon les gens vont sortir
de Montréal et ma fille elle était ça
mais est-ce qu'elle va pouvoir payer les
taxes et tout ça ils sont près de 80 à
assister à cet atelier d'information
donnée par le groupe Montréal pour tous
c'est environ deux fois plus de
propriétaires que par les années passées
souvent les gens ont peur des chiffres
ont peur de sol'évaluation les codes ça
c'est que nous notre but c'est de dire
oui vous êtes capable de comprendre ça
oui avec un peu d'aide vous êtes capable
de comparer votre valeur
hors de la présentation on explique que
la Ville de Montréal mais à la
disposition des propriétaires une liste
de 14 transactions immobilières
effectuées dans leur secteur
le moteur pendant 25 ans pour la Ville
de Montréal selon ce spécialiste ils
doivent ensuite en cibler quelques-unes
qui s'apparentent le plus à la leur se
déplacer aller voir l'état extérieur de
ses propriétés-là c'est les fenêtres les
portes ont été rénovés si la le
contribuable a une propriété qui est en
très mauvais état ou une évaluation qui
est nettement supérieure à cette
transactions-là c'est peut-être un bon
motif pour faire une demande de révision
mais je syndr3 a eu toute une surprise
quand elle a parlé à l'évaluateur
municipale
propriétés qui étaient sur le site web
parce que lui elles sont propres dossier
caché sur lequel il va faire
OK
j'ai l'impression de jouer dans un dans
les doses d'Astérix je ne sais pas
pourquoi je mets pas les valoris quand
il va répondre à contribuant si ça ça va
valeur foncière et bonne ou pas il est
pas obligé de fournir des comparables le
propriétaire a donc fait ses recherches
jusqu'à présent elle a consacré une
dizaine d'heures à monter son dossier je
me suis servi de près cinq maisons que
j'ai trouvé qui avait été vendu j'ai eu
accès aussi aux photos à l'intérieur
parce que maintenant tout est disponible
sur le web les courtiers lorsqu'ils font
une vente font les font une vidéo
souvent des maisons donc j'ai eu accès à
ça
j'ai pu comparer voir les nombres de
chambres il y avait des garages pas de
garage elle pense que sa maison a été
surévaluée ma maison était value au
moins 200000 dollars de plus que ses
propriétés-là qui ont plus d'attributs
plus de caractéristiques que les miennes
c'est ce que le fera valoir quand elle
déposera sa contestation la date limite
et le 30 avril 1200 propriétaires ont
déjà déposé une demande de révision